Las Vegas now as we head into 2023 we
have to check in with ourselves Vegas Dr
Christopher Choi with concierge Wellness
Center has some great tips on how to
address and reassess your reassess
yourself effectively this is all about
feeling good inside and out right doctor
yes yeah yes so physically it is very
important for us to reassess our
physical status in the beginning of the
year especially nowadays you know yes
yeah so that we can figure out what we
need to work on
then we can address it by implementing a
plan to achieve that goal okay
now one of the biggest Pitfall we have
with New Year's resolution is that we're
so excited we make goals that are really
not attainable or achievable so if you
want to be successful please make a
short-term and a long-term goals that
are very reasonable so that you can
actually accomplish it okay and to and
to you know
complement your physical health we also
have to think about our physical
appearance right yes in a healthy way
yes we do so you know as we all know
with the holidays schedules are busy and
we're all running ragged so we feel
physically tired inside but we also
actually feel tired on the outside so
when everything is done come New Years
we look in the mirror and that we may
not like the way we look yeah all that
party and all that champagne but you
know actually
seriously how we look and feel on the
outside can have a tremendous effect on
our overall health absolutely so there
are things we can do to actually address
it okay give us one because we want I
want to move on to the last but
certainly not least one so there are
non-surgical options like what we do in
our office okay if you want surgical
options then you need to talk to a
plastic surgeon okay that's great advice
and then last but certainly not least
like I said mental health can't stress
this enough
so mental health is very important this
year because we all know that green
holidays and post-holiday Seasons there
is an uptick in the depression and
especially because of the pandemic
there's already increasing the mental
illnesses so come New Year you want to
reassess Yourself by asking yourself am
I more depressed or ask your friends do
I look more depressed is there some
problem with me if so then talk to your
doctor and get a referral to a
specialist okay or get a referral right
now to concierge Wellness Center well if
you want to contact me then call
702-463-8080 again
702-463-8080 and we will be happy to
help thank you so much Dr Troy have a
have a good see stay well over there
thank you